i saw the secret life of walter mitty
last night and i really loved it and
made a point of going backstage and
talking to you about it because you
directed this this has been a labor of
love for you yeah thank you yeah because
you usually won't talk to me before the
show i refuse yes it's just i talk to
everybody else but i won't speak to ben
um no thank you they believe they
believe that now it's just like
why does he hate ben
no we um yeah thank you it's been a
great experience been you know working
on it for a while and uh and you're in
it this was fun yeah we have a
we have a quick scene where where your
character appears on our show yeah
because walter mitty he's fantasizing
about uh about being on your show
and uh you're great you get a huge laugh
now it's amazing you are shooting all
over the world in this film and yeah
really challenging environments yeah
like you're in we went to iceland
iceland which was great it's an
incredible place it's a dramatic
landscapes and
very severe uh
changes in in weather and actually ran
into russell crowe there because he was
shooting noah he's doing the movie now
which hasn't come out yet and they were
just leaving as we were coming there and
um and he said to me um it's you know
good luck filming the movie and i'll
tell you one thing you have to dominate
the weather
he told you to dominate the weather and
i said okay russell i think maybe you
can dominate the weather
maybe i could sort of like be friendly
to the weather
but what he meant was and he was right
is that the weather just changes so
quickly you can't like change your plans
you just have to shoot through it and
the weather will do what it does but you
have to just keep going because you get
a windstorm and then it's sunny and then
all of a sudden it's raining and it was
so um you know we followed his advice
it's amazing you jump into the north sea
in one scene from a helicopter and
it was clear to me looking at it i just
does not look like digital animation it
looked like you really did it yeah we
wanted to do as much real stuff as
possible in the movie and uh so we sort
of based our whole shoot around getting
to the north sea at the end of september
when we knew there'd be six to eight
foot swells
we cajoled the weather yeah yeah and um
and so it was great we shot there and it
was crazy because we were all like in
the water and there's a big fishing
trawler and i jumped in and there was a
a stunt coordinator a second unit
director is an ex-marine and he's really
like a tough guy so we did this shot
where i jumped in it was like 40 degrees
popped out and the boat goes by and i
thought okay we got it this is great i'm
shivering he's like no we don't have it
the timing was off we got to do it again
and i'm like really phil do we have to
do it again he's like yeah we got to do
it again and uh
i had no choice at that point even
though i was directing the movie because
you're directing and starring in the
movie and you're like well if phil says
oh phil
so phil's a tough guy yeah so then and
then at one point we had to do a shot
where i was in the water and the boat's
coming to get me so the camera was in
the boat so they left me they dropped me
in the water and then they left in the
boat in this little zodiac to come do
the shot so like the boat went away it's
six foot swells you can't see the
horizon and i just all of a sudden i
wasn't in a movie anymore i was just a
guy in the ocean
and there's this realization that
there's you know if i needed a water
there's no pa to run and get me a water
hopefully they'll find their way back to
me and it was insane there could be a
whale underneath you definitely get well
speaking of which we're going to show a
clip right now from secret life walter
you've just jumped into the ocean yes i
think that that scene i i've jumped into
the water uh because i have to try to
get to this boat and i misunderstood the
pilot and they're sending a little
zodiac to come and get me come get you
let's take a look at this clip from the
secret life of walter mitty
there's a fin here i think
don't fear the purpose i don't think
it's a purpose i'm telling you it's a
purple
it will protect you from the sharks
okay
come here
hey
okay
that's a shark that's what i said
[Applause]